non
alors
alors les gens et ce que nous sommes
actuellement en direct je me le demande
depuis tout à l'heure je suis en train
de galérer voir si salagou si ça passe
ou six nuls
alors on va voir ça tout de suite je
sais pas si ça marche
alors ce que je vais faire c'est que je
vais juste branché monde place même
écran faites vos commentaires ou quoi
parce que la [ __ ] salaire de vachement
laguë alors je vais direct mettre ça sur
l'autre écran les gens ne bougeait pas
eu
j'espère que ça va réussir à marcher ma
foi ça m'arrangerait fortement je suis
un peu en panique
a priori ça a l'air de marcher a juste
un petit 30 secondes eux les gens se
moquent de moi parce que j'étais en
galère pokerface allez c'est parti on y
va les gens crient will go on va
commencer un petit live sur sneijder
alors n'hésitez pas à me dire juste je
branche mon deuxième écran et on y va
excusez moi c'est avoir un vrai que je
laisse ça du coup je galère un petit peu
a à me à bien faire les choses on va
durer quelques heures
bon alors je branche mon deuxième écran
pour voir commentaire s'il a des soucis
de connexion ou quoi c'est quand même
quelque chose d'incroyable jamais en
arriver là wes deuxième fils
un premier combat pro b live sur youtube
et avec mac os en carton j'avoue que
c'est chaud alors on va y aller oui
c'est [ __ ] les câbles vous avez là on
va brancher salah directement hop voilà
allez c'est parti
tac on va y aller les gens du voyage ici
vous me faites pas trop en train de me
tailler et de vos fous de ma gueule
on va mettre ça là on va stopper le live
et on va y aller on va y aller tout
simplement alors je ferme tout je ferme
ça aussi pâques et on va voir si tout
marche bien
stop voilà alors dites-moi si tout
marche bien les gens en tout cas on va y
aller voir ce que ça donne
on va se retrouver tout de suite sur
slider alors j'espère que le son sera
assez fort pour vous alors slender pour
commencer ce ladder ziari vole donc
c'est le nouveau slender donc vous savez
avec les bêtes de graphismes que je vous
avais dit j'ai fait le prologue bon un
petit peu chiant avec des écritures fais
pas chier dessus
bon
on va zapper cette étape un petit peu
chiante on va dire est que passer à la
première mission alors ça va être bien
évidemment le but du jeu trouver les
pages comme dans tout cela ne sait ce
qu'il faut faire
alors on va y aller j'espère que vous
entendez assez bien le son que ça lag
pas trop ou quoi mais je checke vite
fait les commentaires sur la gauche
de toute manière allez on commence
n'oubliez pas qu'ils aient un petit
décalage de 30 secondes mais cette fois
c'est bon on y va un [ __ ] alors
j'espère vraiment que vous arrivez à
voir quelque chose ou quoi je peux pas
streamé en très grande qualité à cause
de macau suis pas un ouvrier qui paie là
dans mon garage et qui produit une
connexion internet potable enfin potable
savoir pourquoi d'ailleurs
bref ces partis première mission on y va
on est chaud on est chaud cacao
je vais juste devoir à attendez je vais
juste devoir retirer vite fait changer
la fin du live c'est non vous allez être
baiser et c'est pas trop mon but
donc on va aller là à c'est quand m 55
c'est très bien parfait ni quelle salle
de contrôle en direct voilà alors on y
va
j'espère que ça marchera assez bien que
ce sera potable en tout cas j'espère
vraiment est bref
au pire ça ne marche pas et je fais
cette vidéo dans le vin ce qui serait
assez incroyable bon allez c'est parti
on y va je suis chaud là savez quoi je
vous cache pas je suis prêt pour
défoncer pour défoncer slender c'est son
père sa mère ses enfants est où là
l'image de la route j'avais fait un
super blague là je vois là elle et elle
était elle était mauvaise elle était
théorêt j'ai fait à surfer de jacques
faty à 16 heures ça se voit pas gbagbo
mur bon allez c'est parti je crois que
ça c'est l'après émission correspond un
peu à la map de la bêta ou je crois ça a
l'air en tout cas de correspondants le
mode de la bêta on a actuellement 1300
sur ce live c'est assez stressant j'aime
l'idée live tout court sur youtube alors
où est la page la mata mata mata dans
mes cours à nancy on est une autruche et
la place d'un homme on va pas être
d'accord 1 messieurs dames moi je vous
le dis [ __ ] bon ok donc surtout règle
numéro 1 ne jamais se retourner les
numéros de ne pas avoir peur d'une
feuille prix numéro 3 quand on les
croise antilles mais ils sont sérieux en
fait je pense que vu que j'ai pas arrêté
de retour windows pour régler le truc du
light linder et doit croire que c'est
une grosse pagaille et d'amateurs de
tourner le matin a lieu forme merde
allez allez on y va
oh [ __ ] de merde mais vous êtes servi
là il vit porte quoi il a un sac de
militaires sur le doubs quoi la mecque
pourrais-tu courir sinon tu marques dans
la rue car ce sont deux et ça fait
physique ça me tue trop avec bobo
paradis pourquoi j c alors bien
évidemment comme tout comme dans chaque
thunder malheureusement ne se retrouve
pas trop dans la forêt c'est à dire que
nous sommes pas vraiment des zones de la
forêt sommes des hommes civilisés à la
base dans le prologue pour vous dire ce
qui se passe ils arrivent en bois
sérieux là bas moi j'suis pas d'accord
avec ça la wau d'un prologue en fait
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive pour se
balader en forêt mais qui va super
moindre là pourrait comme un débile et
il fait nuit il trouve une maison ils
trouvent une lan il ressort de la maison
est là c'est cet épisode là qui commence
voilà donc un côté sérieux là t'es
sérieux là
et pourquoi il faut autant de briques
ont émargé fait des claquettes ou quoi
le bonhomme vert tél non mais sans dec
quoi [ __ ] à vaches
alors on a une chance [ __ ] non mais
moi faut pas me faire ça mais il émane
la mecque
ok donc pas dans la salle de bain alors
ce qui est absolument génial entraîneur
c'est que vu que tu es mort de trouille
tu perdre toute capacité à réfléchir tu
ne peux plus tu n'arrive plus à
réfléchir en fait d'or concrètement tu
peux pas tuer perdu voilà par exemple
sonneront comme un connard et je me
concentre sur ce que je dis pas ce que
je machine j'ai peur d'affronter jeu bon
mais consentie pas à s'y sentir le gros
molosse qui fait sentir humaine bon
[ __ ] je vous promets que j'ai une
crampe là haut au milieu des poumons je
ne trouve pas logique du tout je crois
que c'est là que mon truc un pet fait
alors je sais que à la version bêta vous
m'avez anglais puisque j'ai pas trouvé
une certaine page mais elles étaient
transparentes dans un mur en fait donc à
temps ça doit être de l'autre côté si tu
pourras te faire des claquettes ça
m'arrangerait patao on a trois aux
[ __ ] je vais perdre mon sang-froid je
vous le dis direct à une page ici là
ok on se bat on se bat on te barres on
verra plus tard gallas est à moi alors
je crois que le seul choix a battu
sochaux envisageable ou à l'aff est l'as
bon visage blanc bon bah sur le chemin
elle quitte descente
[ __ ] bon bah on va partir dans l'autre
sens vous savez quoi
1 parce que c'était leur persécutés gens
même aux toilettes il n'a aucun respect
c'est un homme affreux c'est un même
pied galère je peux même pas actualiser
vos commentaires voir ce que vous dites
tom enders non non je refuse de perdre
au moins on connaît chemin si on perd on
connait chemin on pourrait retourner
ok je ne veux pas faillir à ma mission
[ __ ] au clairon m il faut être
difficulté facile on est des gros lâche
temps difficiles tu prends une page
estelle et bordères toile à lacets zou
kai fait et défonce direct d'un coup de
tête blanche là
[ __ ] c'est me de la mayo sur la gueule
sommeil bref on y va on y va
hop hop hop hop hop hop à les allèles
marche comme un bonhomme h comme un
bonhomme et assume comme un bonhomme on
est déjà venu ici plus tard ah j'en ai
marre pourquoi ça senti cela ne remet
pas non il ya une voiture là bas on
n'est pas allé ici [ __ ] l'homme
pervers et écoute élevé de la rivière
est tombé sur nous [ __ ] multi ce que
vous aidez moi vivre sans dec essais ont
monté en haut du poteau
non non non non non non non non mais non
mais tu es sahel écran il senti comme
pas permis [ __ ] mais je crois qu'on va
devoir commencer un j'ai tellement été f
quelques que ça sentait la fin du monde
là j'ai beaucoup trop et f k ce qui fait
que du coup bas balle et le jeu s'est
dit que je reste en position foetale
dans un coin hein comme dans un certains
épisodes
et que du coup pas gt gt un vieux gars
et donc il ordonnait à 16h devenir mais
tu es très très vite un mois je veux pas
tamagno sur la gueule ce land art alors
oui je crois qu'ici et une page
non ici il n'y a rien là bas et un
chemin on va y monter juste après mais
je crois qu'à une page là bas merde non
en fait non c'est un gros cul de sac
bon les grandes villes comme moi [ __ ]
mais ça met six länder
sacré slender en tout cas les graphismes
mais ils sont tellement il est sérieux
oh [ __ ] je regarde vite fait à gauche
je remets la vie sourit l'était la
romagne on va devoir couper par la
droite là bas c'est bon on a appris la
page ça s'est fait dans la pop là dans
les rochers en apd est un [ __ ]
moi y aller [ __ ] bordel
[ __ ] mais comment il a éduqué cet
homme là c'en est qu on lui a collé un
chiffon sur la gorge et vient qui veut
oh [ __ ]
oh non alors pourquoi très bien son
aspect du vernis aujourd'hui nouvelle
vidéo met cap sur ma chaîne sur le doigt
voilà maintenant qu'on est détendu brad
fois pour prendre la chose il faut que
ça sèche par contre c'est vous
oui j'ai l'habitude d'en mettre alors
j'ai juste regardé vite fait ce que vous
dites si ça marche ou pas normal que ça
lag luiz alex tu t'es tam singer
d'accord bon ok bref on est reparti boss
aller à sa pub elle vers nice a pu son
mec
allez on y va alors premièrement hawks à
pâques à ce week-end à eauze blame for
and shout d'accord super cool
j'en ai même à roland de mcdo de manger
tu es sénia bon allez on passe dans les
champs et des gangsters ne suis pas le
chemin
on fait du moment eu beaucoup pour la
fougère enfin bon allez on y va alors
que at il il ya une voiture voiture avec
des faits on est déjà allé c'était un
gros piège et par un bidon d'essence
pour cramer slender il n'y a rien mais
c'était pas la voiture 2ieme pajama
merci la voiture de chez paquet jocelyne
d'heures peut-être l'histoire de ce
länder il passait son code lorsqu'en
forêt il est bizarre
philippe bies l'abaya une autre voiture
alors on va les suivre l'autre voiture
je sais que si on est là slider peut pas
venir dans le prologue il y avait des
dessins sur les murs des zones situées
au pied d'une d'une tour comme ça
seigneur ne peut pas venir
alors va savoir pourquoi peut-être at-il
peur des grandes choses
il faudrait t'il pas qu'il tombe sur mon
pénis bon allez on y va on y va on y va
où pouvons-nous aller je me le demande
je sois louer dire que vous êtes 1700
vous y étiez j'avais plus que tous ont
valu ces normes
bon allez on y va on y va on y va monte
et monte de la colline cloche-pied
monter la colline à cloche pied et le
monde de la colline avec un thunder a
c'est que qui veut lui aux [ __ ] c'est
un flash
peut-être que je me concentre non à part
une grosse bd cinar extender n'y a pas
de page que magnifique merci beaucoup
bon allez faut en fait faut vraiment se
retrouver très vite de sorte à ce que
cela ne soit pas encore déchaîné en mode
mono auto vous au mcee alors voilà alors
une page
on avait passé la terreur c'est bon de
pages on a deux passions à deux pages
on peut y aller on peut continuer il
faut que je regarde leurs envies de fait
le stream on a quinze minutes 15-10
minutes 10 minutes pour faire un truc
potable les gens comme l'eau de ces
toilettes y est tu t'appelles colette tu
veux boire l'eau des toilettes tu
ressembles à une arête
alors ici on avait trouvé une poche tout
à l'heure non c'était pas là oui il me
semble que c'etait pas là après des arts
dont la forêt c'était des bancs tables
et bancs mois alors la vraie mais c'est
quoi la difficulté va être facile
c'est la difficulté farida difficulté
grand large à aller bakar alors oui non
mais là voyez pour pour plus de fun je
vais à difficulté ultra hardcore
spécialement créé pour moi d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que j'ai du mal parce que
sinon vous vous doutez bien qu'en mode
normal ou facile
j'aurai un peu torcher le jeu bon ma foi
c'est ce que ça
[ __ ] elle est où la page
[ __ ] mais c'est a été dans les
chiottes n'était pas là n'était pas là
alors où elle était à l'été où elle
était aux étés où tom j'ai cru voir un
standard c'est pas j'ai cru voir voler
ces objets comarch anna howell bon vous
savez quoi
on va circuler en viendra après
peut-être qu'elle sera pas entre temps
la bâtarde et peut-être que c'est en
dehors aussi
entre-temps des phares le statut pour
tous alors c'est peut-être là par contre
don vient comment on va faire on a
peut-être je peux pas malheureusement de
nombreux commentaires en live puisque je
dois cliquer sur un bouton et ça fait
que je dois faire un gros retour une
dose pas très bon nous pouvons nous le
pouvons aller ma foi pouvons nous aller
je me le demande gm pierre et je décèle
un colis ne dans la tente
voilà c'est cet endroit que je pensais
avoir vu tout à l'heure
hélas hélas là on va faire comme le
nomme fort boyard une grosse page on va
arrêter on va t être immobile au 6/9 à
venir merde merde merde alors dépêché
nous dépêchons nos métiers de bouche on
espère un grand coup et on est parti
c'est une feuille
non c'est un moins jeunes des moins
jeunes des toilettes publiques ce qui
ferait au hall oui les toilettes
au fait pourquoi pourquoi des toilettes
publiques alors qu'il ya carrément un
grand truc annonce doit être un petit
local au temps pour moi aux bâtards tu
vas le toilettes
cela n'arrive pas justement d'aller se
te plaît
gros malaise de cette allée jusqu'à
lancer un nouvel endroit super [ __ ]
mais cela ne remet des cartons à bata
[ __ ] mais ça non mais ça met les gens
mais c'est bon [ __ ] non mais ça mais
comment voulez qu'on fasse quoi que ce
soit il est en outre où nous ne pouvons
rien faire
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] on n'est pas
en étant au courant mais tant qu au nom
du jihad guerre sainte et qui fauche des
tentes et un tu peux pas dépêcher un
milieu aussi passé sont trois fois ça
sans ambages peux vous dire que cet
homme là serait mort depuis des années
n'aurait pas eu son bac d'ailleurs là
bas
oui encore encore feront probablement
une page un [ __ ] si on assiste les
gens juste rester c'est juste raison à 6
[ __ ] nous en manque deux nous en
manque deux nous sommes en deuil live se
termine dans dans donc dans cinq minutes
100 minutes de patience ne te cacher
mais tout va tout repoussé on va à
rembourser le chômage va pouvoir s'y
retrouver le manque d'aires de pages est
pas arrivé là bas je partirai scannant
laisse ça fait plus flippant et tout ce
qui en fait si vous voulez si on
seulement on pouvait voir mon ombre
verrez qu'en fait c'était claqué une
caméra et qui se baladent au vernet plus
cette horrible
allez allez allez allez non non non
c'est non a dit de faire ça je veux
juste d'illuminer en mettant ma grande
lampe torche dans son gros nez pendant
sa grande coucou à tant faire tout le
tour vers la gauche
franchement c'est un peu la merde moi je
trouve ça pas super sympathique
il a utilisé la téléportation chichewa
ou au cou on va l'avoir à la barre alors
éteint les lumières qu'on n'a pas besoin
lumière n'ont pas besoin de lumière on
sait qu'il faut aller tout droit on
était ouvre dans l'exploration il ya une
voiture leur fallait qu'il est trop
bizarre dans sa vidéo c'est quoi ça là
bas
je suis dit allez je suis dit allez je
suis déjà les bâtards ce petit bruit ça
veut dire je suis derrière toi mon âme
et la peine feuilles ici là mais c'est
aussi ça notre app qu'on tape enfants
retournent aux toilettes ou élever la
dernière on a pris c'est là au contraire
boîte à les considérer sous ses comptes
elle fait là bas s'est rodée puisque je
fais les feuilles elles bougent pas
lucas c'est toi qui fais ça devant ton
écran déjà poursuit olé olé genre oh oh
on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas le choix
faut y aller par là on n'a pas le choix
faut y aller vous allez faire la
toilette pour la lutte au maintien pas
tant [ __ ] [ __ ] faut carrément y
aller la focale monial et là comme au
kfc quand tu as faim très toit peut
aborder un thème peu en vidéo sur
sneijder
un homme fait la grimace bizarre son
vidéo sur sneijder je pète un câble
sérieusement ça me rend ouf
des toilettes voit les gens on trouve la
page là dedans et je bouge je vous
promets que se trouve la page de là
dedans je trouve qu'on a pas on trouve
la poste là dedans je vous promets que
si on trouve la page d'anna on a on a on
a gagné on a défoncé slender après au
moins six vidéos un prétendent elles le
peuvent
c'est bon après tant de haine après tant
de peur après tant de frayeur après tant
de choses mal qui nous sommes à effet on
a tous déjà pleuré devant des dizaines
d'heures on a tous déjà plusieurs jours
aux bâtards aujourd'hui je prends mes
résolutions sur un an grâce aux luttes
ou un syrien nous rassure un tournoi
s'il ya dollars son lit tour marie tour
la scène nocturne maurice leenhardt à ta
à la fin
un mec mais ça fait ça vite tellement
que ça je suis paralysée
à londres le brent à l'amp mec elle est
où cette page on la trouve et à leur ok
on va faire part logique là tu va tout
droit
ok là tu va tout droit la hyène petites
salles lé pas dans la petite salle
donc tu continue d'aller tout droit tu
continuer d'aller tout droit tu vas à
gauche tu vas à gauche elle n'est pas à
gauche elle n'est pas à gauche regardant
les wc
oh ouais c'est quoi ça oh oh non au
cours pour un petit enfant au alors là
je vous fais pas dance get down et à
tatinghem à 1 et un temps qu'elle dans
un état d'un cas d'un audit interne et
un temps j'adore et un tintin on m'a bel
- lucien barrière
ok bon on va telle connerie les landes
c'est déjà la fin de ces petits live si
vous voulez un nouveau live sur slender
pour le deuxième épisode il reste trois
épisodes n'hésitez pas à dire en
commentaire à des vidéos n'hésitez pas
de lâcher un groupe ou d'un gros pouce
vert russie sur la vidéo si vous voulez
plus de lave j'ai un petit peu galère à
le faire j'espère que ça s'est bien
passé pour vous ça pas trouvé quoi que
c'était cool
et puis voilà le live sera dispo en
redif sur ma chaîne j'espère qu'il sera
pas trop de mauvaise qualité qui sera
c'est cool
en tout cas je vous dis à bientôt tout
le monde piece by